you know britney spears made it clear
that she no longer wants her father is
one of her conservators
well now brittany has officially taken
action to remove him
[Music]
okay guys great news this is just a
groundbreaking day and i feel like my
life is changing as we speak
upward bound yes britt's been on a
posting spree
modeling bikinis petting a pig showing
off dresses
and answering questions if i had to
choose a potato chip i would have to say
i would choose a real deal
play but she was over the top ecstatic
not over her attorney's major court
filing yesterday
but her first touchscreen tablet i came
to the kitchen
i saw something i ordered and it is a
freaking new ipad
i am so excited my kids have owned one
i've never owned one
in yesterday's filing obtained by et
britt's attorney
matthew rosengaard asked that the court
remove her father as conservator
as early as the court will permit
arguing quote
miss spears should not be forced to
continue to feel traumatized
lose sleep and suffer further what's the
timeline of removing jamie out of this
conservatorship
as soon as possible britney's dad hit
back hard today
in his response jamie claimed that last
month britney's personal conservator
jody montgomery
called him concerned that britney was
not properly taking her medications
and refused to even see some of her
doctors
he also claims that jody said britney
was mentally sick
and brought up the idea of putting
britney under a 5150 psychiatric hold
jaime added that four days later jody
backtracked on most of the details and
discounted the need for a 5150 in the
filing
jamie denied britney's claim that he
objected to her trip to hawaii last
month
saying quote his sole motivation has
been his
unconditional love for brit
[Music]
iggy azalea who collabed with britney in
2015
spoke exclusively to et about her
support for brittany
i grew up watching her and i idolized
her and i still do
and beyond the fact that we collaborated
together she put her faith in me to
produce that music video for her and
develop the cover art and all these
other things and she's the only artist
that ever really gave me that
[Music]
opportunity
you